Hi, welcome back to the show. Let's take a look at the solution here. So, our
loadAsset function should first check the gCachedAssets dictionary for the file
name that was provided if the file is not present in the cache, then the result
of this access will return no. If this happens we know that the image has been
loaded, and we need to actually issue a load call. From here we can actually
create our image do our on load, and set our source. Once is all done we
actually set the image object as the value to the key of asset name inside of
the cache. This allows us later, once again, to go through, query for a name
and get an object, which you can see down here. If the object has already been
loaded, then when we query for it, we'll get a something back, which allows us
to pass that image object to the callback function that was given to us.